I've always thought that because I
always felt My Views are so different
from the world and I always feel like
how come the world is so driven by their
feelings you could just be off
[Music]
we're gonna be talking about one of
Nick's favorite topics today what is it
Napoleon complex
what do you mean why is that one of my
favorite complex what topics why is that
one of my favorite complex
is that one of your favorite things no I
don't know this guy's branding me with
okay sex after
um I haven't had sex in a really long
time
that's a lie here
almost too long too long some I'd say
Okay aren't you married I am married
okay yeah yeah so apparently I'll just
just busy schedules that's what happens
when you get married you have less sex
kind of we're just working too much so
it's keeping quiet so a new study has
found that
shorter people
are more likely to be psychopath that's
true really I agree with that Napoleon's
complex what what's the height yeah well
what is the short U.S scientists have
studied the condition also known as
Napoleon complex and discovered that
smaller people are more likely to have
dark Triad personality traits but like I
got a question I got a question so like
depends on like the average so let's say
you are a Samoan man and everyone around
you is six five then if you're a six
foot dude you're a short guy Napoleon
complex relativity yeah it's all about
relativity so it's like Asians are like
let's say five five to five seven right
and that means like what that means if
you're five two you're short I'm your
shirt to the world but still dude five
two is pretty short yes if you're a guy
kind of
yes please out of all the of all the I
know a lot of guys
that's cool that's cool man that's dope
thanks man some would say he knows more
guys than girls because he's really fond
of men that's absolutely true that's
absolutely true it's just part of the
business that I'm in but a lot of guys
that I know that are like five two or
below they're like
short and they're kind of insecure about
it
they are kind of psychopath
I thought you were going to be
supportive they're not very likable can
I be like they're not I thought he was
gonna say something different
hey let him speak his truth guys I
remember I was at a rave right I was at
a rave and then the security guys were
trying to um go up to this group and
take their drugs and all that and then
this guy that was like 5-1 he had no
shame to step on top of a bench and talk
down and talk [__] to them that way so
he wouldn't go up like that but he
jumped on top of a bench that was in the
back where everyone was smoking kind of
smart and he got up like like this and
then he started talking [__] back down
to the he was going down to them like
that and then all the security guards
were looking like this and I was like
that was one of the funniest things
did he go hold on hold on and then he
got on the bench oh they're they're like
fighting and then he just got up on top
so he could start talking [__] like this
yeah that's effective yeah very
effective because they were listening
okay yeah he embraced the shortness no
he he got on his booster yeah yeah so
the uh the dark Triad personality traits
apparently it's like a test um it
includes characteristics like a lack of
remorse an inflated self of self a sense
of self-importance and narcissistic
Tendencies that's definitely would you
agree Nick I think that's true kind of
the study was I think it spotless uh
which was published uh the personality
and individual differences Journal found
that shorter people are more likely to
be antagonistic as they try to offset
the disadvantages they encountered due
to their height good everybody's trying
nobody's disagreeing with the song I
think that's kind of true is it also
relative to just the way you perceive
the world
because you have to look up at everybody
you're like [__] man well no I'm saying
like something you're looking down at me
and [__] some people don't think they're
short I mean some don't think they're
tall but they could be
you know I mean like it could be it's so
individualistic too like we know people
who are fat but they think they're buff
yeah yeah sitting right here dude and
there's people that are short but they
don't think they're short we had this
fat ass friend that put his fat [__]
arm next to Bart and then he was like
Joe don't you wish your arms was as buff
as ours
no it's it's like a baby's arm it's soft
and gentle babies yeah and then he
[__] puts it next to Bart's arm like
yeah don't you wish it was big like
hours I don't even know why you said
that I don't even know what we're doing
because Bart it would never be like and
he's like how big he said it and he said
it seriously yeah we're just I was like
I don't even know what we're making
steaks or something that'd be such a
great joke if he was [__] around no
he really he was serious he was being
serious he has body dysmorphia in the
other way oh yeah whoa that's kind of
cool though that's probably the best
best case we'd be going shopping for
jeans and [__] and he's all getting like
[__] 30 ones when he should be a 48
or something God damn those are but you
know when they're serious
he makes it fit dude he makes it fit
when they're serious like that like oh
you know like don't you wish are your
arms as big as ours I love that like I
remember a guy and um yeah I think it
was post College he goes man you know
what but High School I was just good
looking but now I got the personality to
go with the good looks and people are
like
say what you did it and he was serious
so no one could say anything you
couldn't really joke about it because he
was so serious because that's probably
the best though dude you know it's a
weird a weird thing I noticed is that
like I totally forgot that short people
might have that complex
oh wow my watch said it's not sure she
understands what you're saying she's
offended I met it I got a friend that I
met and he's like a short like way
shorter than most Asians anyways but
he's such a confident dude and so cool
and he has like the personality of like
a 6-2 dude that's what I mean there's
people like that I think it's like
relative to how you perceive yourself
but the funny they're rare but like the
fact that I'm noticing that and thinking
it's Unique kind of gives that away like
I shouldn't think that that's like
remarkable oh I see but like it's
there's a flag going off that's like wow
you're actually really cool for a short
guy right yeah
it's like noticing on the other side
yeah like that shouldn't be
replace short with black and just
recently like just just say it again I'm
just curious like what it sounds like
yeah
all right so check it out I got this
homie right is that uh an example of a
Napoleon complex or not no it's an
example of there's an acknowledgment in
your mind that it no no I mean I I
understand from your perspective I'm
saying like for like somebody who
happens to be short but like is able to
like
confidently just like be himself but
then that I think is different from
Napoleon because I think that is more
like he himself is just yeah he doesn't
see kind of like over compensate
overcome so yeah I understand that's
what it comes down to he's like super
charming and cool and like everything
that you would think like the big man on
campus but he's like a little guy yeah
like that's unique that's like a unicorn
like I know God yeah that's a unicorn
for sure and so because as soon as you
say he's confident it's like how many
people do we know that's confident in
general yeah in general yeah and then
and then throwing the fact they're five
foot two yeah so then you know that's an
anomaly or yeah that's like Tim he he
doesn't have a psychopath bone in his
body but he's a very confident like kind
fun guy like his unicorn yeah so check
this out this is uh I looked this up uh
The Dirty Dozen test
um basically is a scientifically
validated and shortened version of the
dark Triad test like the dark Triad test
The Dirty Dozen measures the socially
undesirable traits of narcissism
machiavellianism and psychopathy the
dark side test is often used by police
in the courts in psychiatric Wards and
evaluation and even in big corporations
so I'm gonna ask some questions question
one of twelve I tend to want others to
pay special attention to me disagree or
agree agree agree okay we're all in
entertainment we can't disagree all
right I'm moving this over to agree I I
have to say I do think I'm a psychopath
we are at the end of the test already
Mark can we just answer some questions
yeah I think so too I've always thought
that that always felt My Views are so
different from the world and I always
feel like how come the world is so
driven by their feelings
that's how I've always felt you could
just be autistic too that could be it
I don't think they call this a
psychopathy I think that what they call
this low emotional
um like is that the same thing though I
think well I have empathy like I feel
for like I'll watch Kung Fu Panda and
I'm crying and [__] I don't think I'm
not sure Psychopaths can have
um that empathy that's what that's the
difference oh yeah you just don't even
have it I see because I I empathize for
people like I feel when people go
through something bad like I feel for
them a lot because I mean sometimes
being pragmatic can be thought as
psychopath or you could have psychopath
type thoughts over time so for example
like let's say you become like a world
leader right over time you become numb
to certain things you're exposed to like
choosing a decision between
um invading this country for oil or this
country for something else but you have
to do it because it's going to make your
country better yeah and that's the
reality of like Modern Warfare right you
have to do it both decisions you're not
a psychopath but then like you grow to
understand well but that's not talking
that's not talking about common people
though you know what I'm saying okay go
through the questions that come like
generalize understanding I have used
deceit or lied to get my way agree or
disagree yeah and that's all guys yeah
I'm like who has some point I tend to
exploit others towards my own end
exploit I don't know that's almost the
same thing but I don't know about it
that's like being an opportunist yeah I
feel like it's more of a pattern it
sounds like it's more of a pattern oh
yeah I would say disagree I would say
disagree for all y'all I'll say strongly
agree dude
[Laughter]
I tend to manipulate others to get my
way
yeah everyone does all three of these
lastings could be forging my mom's
trying to report cards I've done all of
those at Chipotle already I tend to lack
remorse oh can I get the extra can I
just have a little bit more hey the the
you know the additional I've done all of
those at Chipotle I think I think what
what's different though is that uh I
think what's different though is is how
Psychopaths execute these things they're
not long lasting so like people who
think long term they can do these things
but they don't skin the Sheep they Shear
the Sheep so like basically it's not
about like exhausting those resources
and burning people out as you go along
it's more like that's why those two can
be confused confusing right like one
could be exploitation while other can be
like a long
time of employment
so like there's a difference between
yeah so slavery basically but then
it's like how how much are you giving to
your team versus like someone who's
completely
taking all the resources and everything
this person's energy has yeah I tend to
lack remorse
I don't think that's true I don't think
so we all have guilt we all have yeah
yeah I have used flattery to get my way
Chipotle Chipotle Chipotle I love your
hat I tend to seek Prestige or status is
that what I tend to seek Prestige or
status yeah I ordered three burritos
this week to make it uh it's all
Chipotle
this just this just sounds like driven
people I tend to not be too concerned
with the morality of my actions yo this
just this just this just describes sales
people that's all it is I tend to be
callous or insensitive oh no no no I try
to be sensitive yeah sometimes I think
I tend to want others to admire me I
don't give a [__] about that I wouldn't
be making fun of myself I
tend to be cynical
that's just fun only torturically
cynical yeah
I tend to expect special favors from
others no that's weird that's just
entitlement unless they're sexual hell
yeah
yeah all right so dirty dozen results
uh says you versus the population
average
we're the average no no this is actually
funny you versus the population average
in terms of narcissism we as a
collective have 63 that's higher than
the population yes
uh well we're [__] honest in terms of
machiavellianism we have 69 which is
almost double the population I don't
know what that means something about
Tupac
[Laughter]
in terms of how Psychopathic we are we
are 25 which is about the same as
average and then in terms of the average
in general we're at 52 Which is higher
than average so this makes us 18.83
darker than the average I think this
test sucks and we should take a kink
test we passed the Chipotle test my
burrito's way fatter than those yeah I
feel like if you were I feel like if you
were asking a real psychopath these
questions they'd just be like stop
asking me all these questions Anthony
thank you
[Music]